bien merci
alors on va parler boulot c'est bon vous
êtes encore là n'auront pas parler de
travail on va parler du travail de
l'évolution du travail
vous savez que le monde du travail
évolue très rapidement actuellement et
les façons dont nous travaillons vont
évoluer les façons dont nous allons
travailler vont évoluer rapidement et
nous allons devoir évoluer quelques
flashs à la volée demain nous
travaillerons dans des très souvent la
maison beaucoup plus qu'aujourd'hui
un petit peu à la demande en fonction de
nos contraintes personnelles
nous travaillerons dans des centres
partager avec d'autres entreprises à
proximité de nos domiciles
alors nous continuerons de travailler
dans nos entreprises mais ces
entreprises seront penseront à
reconfigurer l'espace de travail pour
précisément encourager la collaboration
l'innovation des formes de des formes de
partage d'informations et d'ailleurs là
le souci de l'entreprise sera de plus en
plus d'encourager cette collaboration à
cette innovation sous toutes ses formes
alors au travers d parmi les les les
salariés de l'entreprise elle-même est
dans un mode beaucoup plus étendue
finalement que celui qu'on a connu
jusqu'à présent des secteurs qu'ils ne
travaillaient pas ou très peu finalement
les uns avec les autres seront appelés à
travailler ensemble pour être plus
innovant plus créé plus créatifs et puis
cette cette collaboration créative elle
va prendre également des formes
au delà de la delà du périmètre de la de
l'entreprise et on va voir de plus en
plus des formes de collaboration se
mettre en place entre les entreprises
dites traditionnelles et puis des
entreprises ou des individus qui vont
collaborer sur toute forme de projets
que ce soit des projets commerciaux des
projets de recherche développement et
même on envisage aujourd'hui cette
évoqué tout à l'heure des projets de
collaboration et de production ne serait
ce que par l'avènement des imprimantes
3d nous serons appelés à nous à nous
former de façon totalement différente de
ce qu'on a connu ces trente ou quarante
dernières années c'est à dire
va faire appel évidemment beaucoup au
wave mais sous des formes extrêmement
variées très ludique et dans lesquelles
nous tous serons appelés à nous former
beaucoup par nous mêmes en continu et
puis on nous demandera dans les
entreprises d'être beaucoup plus
collaboratif mais aussi de prendre des
risques d'innover le droit à l'erreur
sera reconnu et pour reconnaître droit à
l'erreur pour encourager l'innovation il
faudrait que le management tous ces
personnes qui encadrent d'autres
personnes et biens évolue également vers
des modes vers des modes de
fonctionnement qui soit plus alors de
façon assez schématique vert de
l'accompagnement plutôt que plutôt que
le contrôle le coaching plutôt que la
sanction
et puis qui les inspirent plus qu'il ne
qu'il qu'il n'impose donc tout ceci
qu'est ce que c'est bien c'est là c'est
la tendance sur laquelle on on va et
c'est un monde qui devra être autant du
point de vue des salariés que nous
sommes ou des travailleurs que nous
sommes que des entreprises et bien qui
visera à ce que l'on soit plus ce qu'on
appelle plus d'âge il j'y reviens d tout
à l'heure c'est à dire plus collaboratif
plus innovants les plus adaptables
il est aussi plus flexibles alors les
métiers également vont être touchés
puisque on va avoir en fait une une
vague de modification de création et de
disparaît son métier dans des
proportions qu'on n'a jamais connu qu'on
a jamais connues dans le monde
industriel on sait que des métiers vont
être automatisées vont mettre
l'automatiser tout ou partie vous vont
disparaître mais on sait aussi que
beaucoup de métiers apparaissent il ya
aujourd'hui des exemples très concrets
par exemple dans le domaine de la
gestion des data on cherche des datas
scientist assez très en vogue et on a du
mal à les trouver d'ailleurs et
simplement pour vous donner une idée les
les enfants d'aujourd'hui on estime que
les enfants d'aujourd'hui pour la grande
majorité d'entre eux exerceront des
métiers qui n'existent pas qu'on ne
connaît pas encore aujourd'hui alors
qu'en est il exactement ce sont des tout
ça ce sont les tendances ce sont des ce
sont des éléments qu'on peut retrouver
dans la littérature mais ce sont aussi
des éléments que j'ai pu enfin je m'en
suis fait une conviction
lorsque j'étais comme l'a dit
delphine chez microsoft ces cinq
dernières années en tant que drh france
j'ai beaucoup échangé avec des drh des
autres entreprises et tout va dans le
même sens tout va dans le même sens le
problème c'est que la mise en oeuvre de
tout ça aujourd'hui aujourd'hui très
inégale dans les start up ou dans
certaines start up pas tout
eh bien ils mettent naturellement ce
genre de pratique en place mais c'est
également le cas des entreprises dites
libéré comme favy lueger qui sont assez
connus j'imagine que certains d'entre
vous qui ont complètement remis en
question des modes notamment de
management
en revanche quand on regarde les grandes
entreprises implantées si elles sont
conscientes du sujet et bien vont pas
très loin aujourd'hui alors il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont initié
des projets mais ce n'est pas encore
vraiment en place
en tout cas sur le plan du travail alors
pourquoi ces changements maintenant ces
changements maintenant ils sont dus à un
mot clé qui qui a été évoqué tout au
long de cette de cette journée c'est
cesser le numérique ces digital le
numérique sommes là je ne vous apprends
rien c'est un bouleversement majeur je
vous renvoie là à la citation de michel
serres dans son lit petite poussette qui
dit que c'est un bouleversement
comparable à l'avènement de l'écriture
est en fait nous sommes dans une
révolution mais qu'on ne qu'on ne voit
pas forcément les entreprises
traditionnelles celles qui sont
implantés et qui ont mis en place des
process de production des process de
contrôle une forme d'autorité de
commandement continue de fonctionner sur
ces mots delà pour beaucoup mais se
rendre compte aussi qu'elles doivent
aller dans d'autres directions business
elles le font en interfaçant de façon
différente avec les clients un don que
ce soit par le dans les services
bancaires ou autres vous êtes tous
confrontés à une interface plus web et
mais il ya une difficulté à remettre le
modèle intégralement en question et on
voit aujourd'hui émerger des concurrence
directe extrêmement violente émanant de
start up qui sont finalement très très
peu capitalisées au départ et qui
prennent une valeur capitalistique
énorme
rapidement je pense évidemment à hubert
qui a complètement bouleversé qui est en
train de bouleverser le monde du taxi et
puis je pense également airbnb dont la
capitalisation boursière est supérieure
aujourd'hui à celle de la corse est une
entreprise qui est épais qui a été créé
il ya sept ans donc c'est une vague et
qui peut donc menacé tous les secteurs
d'activité
le dire dans les toutes prochaines
années on est donc dans un dans une
configuration qui oblige les entreprises
à se rendre plus réactive et donc à
aller vers cette agilité de
fonctionnement que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure en agilité sans un mot à la mode
mais c'est un cétacé
ça recoupe nécessité d'être plus
collaboratif plus innovant et le
numérique qui est un peu la cause de
cette situation en devient aussi d'une
certaine façon la solution le numérique
permet de collaborer à distance par les
réseaux sociaux par les outils multiples
dont nous disposons que ce soit des
téléphones portables et tablettes et
tout ce que l'on peut faire avec
et finalement on en voit deux de deux
conséquences
il ya nécessité d'y aller d'autant plus
d'autant plus faisable que les outils le
permettent
mais il ya aussi une nécessité d'y aller
si on se place du point de vue de
l'employeur que j'ai que j'ai était
précisément dans l'est dans les
dernières années qui a un intérêt aussi
à ce que les salariés qui utilisent tout
ça chez eux déjà vous utiliser les
réseaux sociaux vous vous avez à l'accès
à l'information vous pouvez vous formez
même par vous même beaucoup plus
facilement qu'avant et bien retrouviez
dans l'entreprise les mêmes modes de
relation de collaboration d'accès à la
formation que ce que vous connaissez de
vous même concernant les métiers et bien
l'explication de cette mutation
extrêmement rapide et des métiers elle
est assez simple et des métiers qui sont
directement interfacée impactés par le
mode de changement d'interface client
il est évident que les métiers de la
vente le métier du marketing doivent se
remettre en cause dès lors que les
entreprises décident d'interfacer
différemment avec leurs clients mais il
ya un autre effet qu'on ne voit pas et
qui peut être plus profond et qui
interpelle c'est l'automatisation
l'automatisation des métiers elles ne
touchent plus maintenant uniquement les
métiers de production comme ça a été le
cas pendant les décennies passées et qui
ont d'ailleurs fermé des usines elles
touchent maintenant des métiers qu'on
qualifiera de d'administratifs de
services de service même élaboré on
n'est pas de simplement dans des dans
des procédures ou des tâches simples
c'est notamment les faits et
l'application du big data à ce monde qui
permet aujourd'hui de trouver de de
trouver des formes d'automatisation des
intelligente qui qui prévoit des
scénarios et qu'ils peuvent
tout à fait se substituer en partie ou
totalement des métiers le cabinet de
stratégie roland berger a fait il ya
quelques mois une à diffuser les les
largement les résultats de ses
prévisions et prédisent 12 pour ce que
12% des métiers actuels seraient amenés
à disparaître dans les dix ans qui
viennent
non mais ça pose un autre sujet que je
ne ferai pas ici mais il est peu
probable que l'on ait les mêmes
proportions de création de nouveaux
métiers
dans le même temps ça c'est un sujet qui
doit être pris en charge impérativement
par les politiques mais c'est un sujet
absolument préoccupant alors la question
qu'on se pose et qu'on doit se poser
c'est faut-il y aller
faut-il accélérer le mouvement de cette
transformation du travail la réponse est
clairement oui même si on y voit des
effets négatifs
je vois beaucoup plus d'effets positifs
et cette transformation du travail il
est nécessaire pour plusieurs raisons la
première raison c'est que la compétition
n'attend pas c'est que comme je le
signalais si des entreprises ne se
remettent pas en question sur le plan de
7 de ses modes de travail et bien le
seront rapidement prises de vitesse
voire elles disparaîtront sous l'effet
de la menace deuxième deuxième élément
en tant qu'employeur les entreprises ont
intérêt à mettre en place un nouveau
mode de fonctionnement au risque de ne
plus pouvoir attirer des collaborateurs
les salariés et même motif de ne pas
pouvoir les garder
quand ils sont dans l'entreprise et on
commence à voir ce phénomène apparaître
dans les entreprises
et puis troisième élément qui est très
important à mes yeux c'est que nous
sommes en retard nous s'en sortir de
façon générale dans les entreprises qui
sont implantées
mais nous sommes en retard
particulièrement en france nous sommes
actuellement en france encore campé dans
des modèles qui sont treize de l'ère
industrielle très contrôle
automatisation bruit automatisation
pardon processus et si on se réfère à
quelques études qui ont été faites
récemment par des cabinets de renom j'en
citerai quelques unes
on a aujourd'hui simplement en france 2
% des salariés qui bénéficient tout ou
partie du télétravail une étude faite
par un cabinet oddo ksar est simple très
récemment il est sorti hier
1 montre que 60% des salariés y aspirent
on a donc un un écart énorme entre la
réalité et l'aspiration des personnes a
bénéficié en partie de sept de ses modes
de travail
je suis très d'autres chiffres d'une
enquête qui a été fait par par capgemini
le groupe capgemini et qui nous montre
assez de façon assez évidente le retard
français malheureusement au travers de
deux exemples en france seulement 20 %
des cadres dirigeants voient les outils
numériques comme très positif 20 % la
moyenne européenne est à 50%
autre élément que je que je porte à
votre réflexion
les salariés français sont avec des
espagnols
ceux qui voient le changement comme une
menace et non comme une opportunité sur
une étude qui a été faite au niveau
international donc nous sommes les plus
réticents pour des raisons qu'il faudra
analyser par ailleurs nous les plus
réticents au changement donc ces
éléments sont très préoccupants et
nécessitent réellement que l'on prenne
les choses en main alors par rapport à
ça que doit-on faire bien par rapport à
ça je pense qu'il n'y a pas de il n'y a
pas d'hésitation il faut se mobiliser
cette mobilisation collective
là je reprendrai la lala nabeul ce qui a
été ce qui a été tout à l'heure présenté
plus tôt dans la journée sur la la la
nécessité que tout un chacun joue nous
nous mobilisions pour participer à ce
mouvement donc interpellé ou les
personnes avec qui nous travaillons les
entreprises
mais il faut surtout les entreprises
elles-mêmes met en place des prod et des
vrais projets considère ce sujet comme
un sujet prioritaire met en place ces
projets mobilisant tous les acteurs
d'entreprise mobilisant les syndicats
évidemment mobilisant les toutes les
couches managériale tous les secteurs de
l'année delà de l'entreprise pour
pousser dans cette direction
et ce sur le long terme je vois deux
actes travaille aujourd'hui sur lesquels
il faut travailler prioritairement un
axe horizontal qui doit examiner dans
l'organisation comment faire mieux
collaborer et mieux innover l'ensemble
de l'organisation
et là ils viennent une évidente une
évite un évident intérêt à y aller on va
parler aussi de
m dans ce type d' approche de bien être
au travail c'est pas un gros mot et je
crois que ce que nous a présenté tout à
l'heure vineet va tout à fait dans le
sens de cette de ces de ce mouvement
puisque il faut précisément remettre le
salarié au sein ou vraiment en priorité
dans cette démarche
et puis va falloir également joué sur un
axe dynamique un axe vertical peut être
mais qui va viser à prévoir l'évolution
des compétences et des métiers parce que
là aussi il faut préparer chacun être
formés à être à être outillés pour
pouvoir affronter les nouveaux des
nouveaux métiers et puis pour recruter
également les métiers dont on a besoin
donc c'est un travail réellement sur le
long terme dans tout ce mouvement là je
dirais qu'il ya il va falloir jouer avec
des formes d' équilibre instable donc
cesser l'oxymore de ma présentation et
ses équilibres instables jeu des sondes
deux trois ordres
il y à la pression du court terme des
entreprises sont toujours
finalement et c'est normal amené à
exécuter le court terme et tout en
exécutant le court terme il faudra il
faut prévoir ce long terme cette
transformation
pas facile deuxième élément il faut
qu'on passe et là je rejoins totalement
ce qui a été dit ce matin par sylvain
kern
il va falloir qu'on me réconcilie une
aspiration la djette à la digitalisation
de forme de dématérialisation
virtualisation c'était le mot delà de
l'information des rapports avec la
nécessaire nécessaire le dessert
renforcement de la relation humaine dire
que ces instants de relation physique
entre les personnes seront peut-être
moins nombreux mais il faut qu'il soit
dense et qu'il soit préparé donc les
deux éléments doivent doivent coexister
et je pense que c'est au prix de cette
transformation que l'on pourra saisir le
meilleur du meilleur du numérique pour
la performance d'entreprise pour dans
certains cas leur survie mais enfin et
surtout pour les hommes et les femmes
qui qui travaillent et pour l'harmonie
entre leur vie professionnelle et leur
vie privée
je vous remercie